it controls cities in Iraq and Syria
it's stolen hundreds of millions of
dollars and has captured a stockpile of
American weapons it is the Islamic State
of Iraq and the Levant a group that's
been making headlines as it gains more
and more territory but what exactly is
ISIL and what's it trying to do I'm
Francesca and this is cheatsheet the
origins of ISIL can be traced to 2003
when us-led forces occupied Iraq as the
Iraqi state crumbled in the u.s.
dissolved the Iraqi army armed groups
appeared across the country including
one tied to al-qaeda this group went
through several leaders including the
infamous Abu Musab al-zarqawi who was
killed by a u.s. airstrike in 2006 by
the time the current leader Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi took over in 2010 it had become
the Islamic State of Iraq but Baghdadi's
ambitions didn't stop at rocks borders a
year into the Syrian civil war he sent
some of his men across the border to
join the fight against the Syrian regime
the group changed his name to the
Islamic State of Iraq and Levant to
reflect their expanding reach by 2014 it
controlled parts of both Iraq and Syria
including oil fields and has since armed
itself with American weapons captured
from the Iraqi army in Syria ISIL didn't
just go after the Syrian army but even
attacked other rebel groups including Al
Qaeda's official wing in Syria
Giavotella nusra al Qaeda wasn't happy
about this and ordered Baghdadi's
fighters to leave Syria and stick to
Iraq but ISIL refused and the group was
publicly disowned by al Qaeda in 2014
and as for finances well the group is
apparently doing pretty well it's stolen
almost half a billion dollars from Araki
banks and the group allegedly has
multiple income streams that include
smuggling extortion oil sales and
private donations
what does ISIL want a single Sunni
Muslim theocracy that stretches across
Syria and Iraq so their opponents aren't
just the governments of those countries
but anyone who doesn't follow their
interpretation of Islam those who don't
soldiers and Shias especially have been
victims of public executions some people
who have broken is al social rules have
been flogged or crucified
but in Iraq the group has found some
sympathy among Sunnis who feel
persecuted by the shia-led government
the government meanwhile says Sunni Gulf
states support ISIL still the group may
have bitten off more than it can chew
its rapid gains have powerful
government's worried with even Iran and
the u.s. talking about fighting ISIL
together
[Music]